how many nieces and nephews you got by
too many I have like seven dude it's
[ __ ] insane right now I got you beat
yeah it's a competition always
what's the number it's probably over ten
how many parents do you have to love
each other uh
[Music]
and welcome back everybody we have
another amazing episode of the careful
boys and we got Steve back in the house
is that Steve I had I'm the woman some
call me the woman the woman woman Nikki
says is that like you're a woman and I'm
like no that's not what it's like is
that what you've been saying all time
believe all women oh man I would never
well that's better
that's better I saw some JK fans dressed
up as you for um
hilarious should make me [ __ ] die
yeah is that just flavor flavor what is
that what's good branding is where it is
that is a good branding it's the Steve
greens it's the Rebrand green is also a
good uh good last name to run with this
the Rebrand was a wild success of kids
are dressing as you for Halloween I mean
come on no one's ever dressed like you
before before the Rebrand nobody was
dressing up as Steve Green nobody gave a
[ __ ] you mean just being naked
basically all right so uh you know we're
in the holiday season so I figured let's
let's chat a little bit about some
holiday so if anybody here have any
crazy holiday traditions family stuff
you know what I mean things that you do
or just wait just pick that face why'd
you make that face because I always feel
uh I always feel sad for the lack no for
the lack of tradition in my family like
there's zero traditions we just don't
really do [ __ ] you don't do [ __ ] not
even as a kid like yeah we would do like
the basic stuff like open gifts you know
but like we we would always like we just
never had a big family so just be like
the people pity that do people be like
oh you never did the holiday stuff no
they just call us lame you know what
though I think that's actually better
than when you used to have uh awesome
holiday stuff in your family bro up and
they don't do it no more I think that is
that's kind of like that right now yeah
yeah there's times where certain family
members are like I'm not gonna do
Thanksgiving if so-and-so is going to be
there wow oh [ __ ] give them the names
who are they oh they're very close to my
family they're almost heads of the
family if you if you want to leave it at
that
and I'm like you guys live in the same
house bro what do you think you can't
not do this you think having
dysfunctional family together fighting
all day during the holidays is better or
just not doing that [ __ ] at all and
keeping the peace and doing it on your
own oh man that's tough I think we do it
I'm okay because like I have a wife in
her family so you dodged it my Escape is
kind of their family so I get to like
kind of maybe it's not a good thing but
I tend to hang out with them because
they're so chill they have so much fun
they're like it's way more laid back
they have a big family and it's like
it's just a fun time so they have
Traditions though yeah yeah they have
Traditions so now you're just kind of
like in their world of tradition I just
do both it happens to work out where
like for Christmas they'll do Christmas
Eve because I guess a brown person thing
where they do they open up gifts right
at midnight and then they'll do like the
poo poo sauce day yeah but what was I
say boo boo sauce uh and then and then
on Christmas day I'll just go to my my
parents house and just kick it with them
so it all works out have you thought
about like trying to bridge this little
divide in your family and like send them
some links to like during World War II
they [ __ ] the the Germans and the
[ __ ] American forces like had
Christmas together but you [ __ ]
can't get along because because what
like she stole money from you a couple
years ago like what the [ __ ] say have
you guys heard about the [ __ ]
ceasefires the Christmas ceasefire yeah
was it World War one or two we have to
look it up first well yeah
yeah I should bring that up yeah that's
actually a good [ __ ] point oh they
could lay down their literal weapons and
grenades by the way but you guys can't
put it away over like and then they're
like shut the [ __ ] up Nick he's like
okay yeah yeah yeah I'm the youngest son
I get the [ __ ] out of the stick they
just dunk on me I go all right I'll go
[ __ ] myself
for something that's that common among
families I'm surprised they never made
Hallmark cards that were like mending
your family
that's too real the kind of greeting
thing you send for like hey I know we're
not in the best of terms yeah but Merry
Christmas and you got to get a Hot Topic
yeah oh yeah that's right we're
Spencer's yeah yeah Spencers what do you
guys do for Christmas I think everything
changed once little kids came into the
paper is it doesn't it make it more fun
though doesn't it make it more festive
um
it makes it like very
um very family like I feel like uh
before the little there was this era
when we were little kids and so
everything was festive and fun and then
we came into this weird like uh teen
realm where like you know it was like we
were too cool for family and then once
we got older all the cousins would be
like [ __ ] let's drink together and
that started getting kind of cool and
then now there's a bunch of little kids
around now like nobody's allowed to be
irresponsible and now it's like it's all
right
and the noise dude the kids just start
randomly screaming your [ __ ] ears
right and my immediate reaction to that
is like okay violence like something's
gonna hurt me and then I'm like okay
don't hurt okay don't do that so you say
don't punch the kids no I don't but I'm
like my you you just recoil you're like
what the [ __ ] is that and you're like is
this little kid like screaming in your
ear like a child's noise will just
immediately give you this response my
sister's kids like could be an X-Man for
the way that it screams like banshees
yeah yeah it's like [ __ ] starts
[ __ ] flying
like it's crazy the vibrational forces
right up in your ear huh yeah we we did
um Christmas we would always do
Christmas at my you know my both my
parents are together they love each
other
like a gesture like that it has to be
directed
we would always do Christmas together
I have parents that love each other but
I have a stepdad now that was a
masterful it's a stepdad I haven't seen
this guy like a month I had to get my
first one in your face
they are in love in your face no so we
would do Christmas at the house right
but then once you once you leave the
house then it's like we'll go back to
the house we try to rekindle that magic
yeah but it's kind of different like you
know people are drinking rum or whatever
and it was fun we actually had I
actually used to look forward to
Christmas Eve at my folks um house and
then we go to Nikki's
um for Christmas Day and Nikki would
join me on Christmas day but now it's
like they have so many [ __ ] kids and
like once you go through the door
it's like you're pushing toys away from
the door as you're opening the door yeah
and then you go in there there's like a
[ __ ] gate for everything there's a
dog gate baby gate
stair gate it's like just show me the
gate yeah it's very [ __ ] it's crazy
right so then I'm like okay well this is
annoying and then when you're just
trying to sit down on the couch with
like some punch like you sit on like a
[ __ ] toy train so I just you know
it's not as fun it's not what it works
you're over it it's for the kids it's
fun to give your nieces and nephews [ __ ]
because you spend way too much time on
it they open it and they don't give a
[ __ ] about anything they go oh yeah and
then like 30 seconds later they're
[ __ ] with like a power cord or
something me and Nikki are in the Target
like
yeah no this is gonna be the [ __ ] this
is gonna be the one and it's like the
kid opens it and throws it behind him
why how many
I have to think that I was we don't
remember
but also my my parents would always be
like you get the present you stand up
and you hug them and say thank you yeah
these little shits don't do that oh you
gotta kick their ass
thank you yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah
little shits dude that's a lot it's a
lot of kids how many nieces and nephews
you got by too many I have like seven
dude it's [ __ ] insane right now on
your your family side so between my so
Nikki's side and my family side there's
like seven of them I have a godson too
it's working crazy I got you beat yeah
it's a competition always
what's the number it's probably over ten
how many parents do you have to love
each other
uh one
how many players one one pair you have
one parent that loves each other they
love themselves one pair
uh I feel like kovid
um
I think bar would have liked that one
that's the problem
he would have been the first one to make
the joke why don't make jokes where I'm
like Jesus
[Music]
I feel like lockdown changed the routine
though for family events
oh
yeah
guys it's not the same it's not the same
for that
we would have a routine for holidays and
stuff but they're not having seen some
of my family members in like two three
years and I got used to it and I like it
right well for some of them we're trying
to change it because like I'm trying to
I'm trying to I'm trying to go like I'm
in Vegas now I'm trying to make
everything Vegas now so I'm like I'm
hosting our first Thanksgiving in Vegas
with your family they're actually all
going they're so far it's Nikki's side
because my folks are dealing with my
grandma situation but
oh I didn't see you my grandma's about
to die oh okay you're updated bam I
don't like that I can't see your eyes
for these moments
I don't even know what you look like you
just look like a Pit Boss I don't even
know who he's looking at right
[Laughter]
news flash dead Grandma's about to crawl
after all that oh yeah my grandma's
about to die yeah that's funny I hadn't
seen him it's funny because [ __ ]
Anthony started the day off like hey
guys we got a real wholesome
everybody
[Laughter]
I missed you guys
he gets a pent up dunks he's been
holding it in yeah this is a good one
for Joe
we're the same way like that you you you
definitely a thousand percent yeah when
you come here a thousand yeah yeah yeah
but I've been unleashing so hard I'm
here to just ask questions today
throat's about to die [ __ ] who you've
been dunking on recently
everybody yeah everyone gets it huh
everyone's pissing you off are you
giving Christmas bonuses to your
S no free labor do we get a Christmas
boat
you get a reduction that's my dog thank
you Joe only 20 this time you get a
Christmas production
oh you guys should have been a part of
JK five years ago you got the whole
December and January off with a paid
vacation and you got paid for the month
when you didn't even have to work and
you got a Christmas bonus and you could
complain about it yep and you can
complain about it as if I'm a [ __ ] boss
a crew to drop the cherry on top now you
can't do that yeah I give you a pay cut
and if you complain you're out bro
at least we have an air purifier hey
that's where your Christmas bonuses so
we can breathe look at this that's how
Chris is about his dude and Loki it does
feel great in here this one thing is
probably worth more than 90 of this
office you think it's Placebo or you
think is really working
he's like can we get this place clean
and I was like
you know what bro every guest was coming
and [ __ ] taking [ __ ] every allergy
man there's a CVS over here all the
guests are like fighting their allergies
coming back since they were kids they're
like oh man I thought it was dormant
Ryan's in here so unless he's like I
never get allergies anywhere else
[ __ ] Walter had to go to the hospital
so as a homeless man you know I have a
bigger threshold for dust and all this
[ __ ] so I didn't even notice and when
you sensitive ass [ __ ] were like okay
Colleen what do you do for holidays
um well my mom moved to North Carolina
well technically South but she's 20
minutes from Charlotte so we're a little
split up so it's just my mom my brother
and I so wait you already lost me at
North Carolina but technically so yeah
well because when I say like Wiley
nobody knows where that is oh look Wiley
I know where Charlotte is so I just say
20 minutes from Charlotte
got it so uh
yeah it's it's South South of Charlotte
it's south of Charlotte North Christmas
oh yeah geography yeah we'll talk more
about it how many bridges are there
I haven't counted I'm still working on
it so are you gonna head up there
um you know I might not this year
because oh it's expensive it's really
expensive it's almost like a thousand
bucks is that a thousand bucks damn just
go to Singapore holy [ __ ] wow for
Christmas is all hot that's not
Christmas bro actually they do Christmas
nicely over there they do yeah in
Southeast Asia I've never seen more
Christmas lights in my entire life isn't
that funny you would never think hey
what's up with Hawaiians in uh Christmas
they put up their decorations and they
always leave it up they just leave it up
all year round yeah and then they go uh
maybe I'll take it down they take it
down October and they put it back up in
November
I just thought they really like
Christmas because I would see it
everywhere yeah there's like a big
statue of surfing Santa at the city hall
and then like this is
so that means he's there forever yeah
they don't take him down what's surfing
Santa no there's like a Santa Claus in
like beat board shorts and stuff and
like so yeah this place is sick yeah
dude Hawaii's the best and then um they
have this massive [ __ ] Christmas tree
in like our Plaza like right then in the
center and then decorate it and it's
like there's it's just a tropical
Christmas but they go pretty hard with
Christmas though the other like day they
had uh Halloween decorations with
Christmas decorations all mixed up and
[ __ ] because they're putting up the
Christmas that's really that's a good
hack you know that's how the Philippines
is right when I was recently in the
Philippines it's almost like uh the
second is almost Halloween everything
has Christmas decorations every mall has
full [ __ ] Christmas music's playing
everywhere we were there in like uh what
was it yeah beginning of October there's
nothing but [ __ ] Christmas everywhere
damn they really like Christmas I got
into the biggest [ __ ] fight with my
dad like like this is probably like five
years ago this is wholesome and now well
it's it's relevant because like we were
talking about and I still I'm not
kidding I don't talk to my dad anymore I
haven't talked to him and I haven't
talked to him in seven years and really
yeah because it was about like is The
Nightmare Before Christmas or Christmas
movie or not or is it a Halloween movie
and he thought it was a Halloween movie
and I thought it was a Christmas movie
oh what's your points wait seven years
because of this stuff
continue so so it he thinks it was a
Christmas movie I think it was a
Halloween movie is that what I said no
he mixed it up
is it worse seven years dude snow I'm
[ __ ] no but you people people really
get into fights about this it's a thing
yeah yeah just like they get into fights
where if people start listening to
Christmas music before Thanksgiving
people blow up they [ __ ] you hate
that right don't you hate that I don't
like that either it's a weird feeling to
me it's a feeling because you have to
the fact that you strongly dislike it is
like a weird feeling to me yeah that's
how I feel I'm on team Anthem I I get it
if you if you're not about it
Thanksgiving is a filler holiday anyway
listen to Thanksgiving music there's
nothing look there's there's nothing me
because we lost this four years ago our
people have been subjugated and raped
our people have to we have to walk
through every Mall already right now and
listen to Christmas movie music we lost
we're crawling around like like trying
to be lost trying to keep our ears
plugged while everyone's like
it's over you guys never get inspired to
just listen to a winter wonderland Jam
or something like in the middle of
summer just one day like I do from time
to time I feel like I think it's
hilarious Mariah Carey's [ __ ] All I
Want For Christmas Is You just right now
and it's April you never you never do
that she has to perform that year round
did you hear that labored sigh
she don't like it a labored sigh that's
judgment that's called judgment I don't
know I just like what I like so you like
year-round Christmas songs no
you're
you're a strong statement I would
actually argue I probably don't like
Christmas songs in general oh wow humbug
even even the new Ariana Grande ones
dude those are wait there's new ones
okay so I like them she's about only on
Christmas okay like on day day off like
Christmas Even Christmas right that's
two days but I'm not driving to JK news
listen to Christmas song what are you
listening try once if you had to pick
one
what is your all-time favorite give me
one that I should listen to that is like
it's beginning to look like
if the crooder ones are good you believe
it before Steve was like oh nice a nice
pre-frame to to Christmas yeah I'll get
you in the mood how about like Jingle
Bells yeah jingle bells jingle bells
jingle bell rock especially what's the
worst kids choir the worst one oh the
[ __ ] the really weird sad ones like
[ __ ] Christmas shoes or some [ __ ] or
[ __ ] my two front teeth or whatever
the [ __ ] nah um oh that [ __ ] sucks yeah
yeah that [ __ ] sucks what's that one
Bruce Springsteen one where he keeps
going holidays are coming that one sucks
the song sucks ass yo what the [ __ ]
that's called butt Rock right it starts
laughing like for the last part and
you're just like why are we listening to
this [ __ ] anything sung by Josh Groban
I'm like I'm out bro I'm out too yeah
I'm out I like Josh Groban uh I can't
say that
I wouldn't lie I lied I lied okay I feel
like Europe is the epicenter of
Christmas and the more you go away from
it the less Christmasy it feels right
because then like the east coast is
Europe's the epicenter that's like Jesus
Christ Christmas the German Christmas
and [ __ ] Derek no but they go hard on
Christmas like they go so hard that
they're like actually not working for
like two weeks that's when the back ends
isn't [ __ ] dude it's it's but I just
feel like Western's capitalization of
Christmas is totally different oh yeah
we corporatized it yeah but we made it
more fun it's Coca-Cola but it goes so
hard that the decorations are way
crazier than ours they have Christmas
markets it's like the 626 Night Market
where there's all these [ __ ] stores
you could get sounds nice it's so good
they got these like Russian ladies
making Cinnabon rolls and [ __ ] and like
hot dogs that go inside of the baguette
and they actually are the villages that
we paint over here on postcards yeah
that's yeah they're the ones we're
building out of gingerbread yeah it's so
good they got this called this mulled
wine thing it's like it's like berries
and fruits inside wine and it's [ __ ]
warm and [ __ ] you can make some old wine
it's so good and it's and then they run
it till even after Christmas
so these Christmas markets they go into
like the first second week of January
[ __ ] yeah see I'm cool with that than
like before Thanksgiving Christmas [ __ ]
I've I don't [ __ ] with that what's the
cutoff like when do you start playing
music day after
day after so Black Friday the one music
are you playing up to Thanksgiving
because there's no real Thanksgiving
music yeah there is [ __ ] Josh grew up
not his Christmas music his regular
music his regular music yeah You Raised
Me Up all November
your parents had a Christmas in in Asia
because I asked my grandma I was like
did you guys do the Christmas [ __ ] and
she goes yeah and I was like well if you
don't have a chimney because a lot of
Japanese homes don't have a chimney
cauliflower Santa come and give you
stuff and she goes oh in Japan they just
hide it around your room and I was
thinking that suspect like how would
they they shouldn't be going into
children's bedrooms that's so hard for
the parents it's so much more difficult
than like just putting it downstairs
like I'm gonna crawl in your kid's room
yeah like a tooth fairy
pulling [ __ ] in so you gotta wake up and
then you just look for presents in your
room this is choosing to live life
harder yeah
yeah everybody else is like let's just
put it in one spot and just lie and tell
the people that a guy came down the
chimney yeah we put it under the tree
it's the easiest much put the tree
wherever the [ __ ] is there anything that
you don't eat or drink unless eggnog
wait no answer that too soon it's
disgusting
why don't you just tear Christmas down
huh yeah eggnog what do you like about
Christmas
um I like spending time with family but
I won't get too
terrible answer yes correct answer was
gifts
and mistletoe I like Santa Claus better
than my parents that cause is way cooler
dude whoa does anybody actually like
eggnog I never tried it I've never had
it Pennsylvania Dutch eggnog is [ __ ]
good but that [ __ ] will blow what's up
it's definitely got a taste of Christmas
spirit but it doesn't mean I like it
what does it taste like can we get some
today cinnamon and egg right and then
listen to Christmas music as we drink it
are you pumpkin spice girl no I'm not oh
I had that earlier I like pumpkin spice
I like you more for that yeah the
Pumpkin Spice Girls need to chill out
it's like they're all on cocaine
it's because it's seasonal
now nowadays
is cocaine
it's a crisis the new epidemic
[Music]